[Music]
self-awareness and the ability to
actually give without expectation are
the two bricks of happiness which is
allowed there to go wrong when you're
stable you can go fast because you're
not worried about judgments that lack of
fear is what gives an entrepreneur an
advantage that lack of fear is what lets
somebody live life in happiness
we're in Jakarta in Indonesia nice
24-hour flight for d-roc and I gonna go
hit the stage a couple hours of meetings
afterwards and then right back in a
plane for 24 hours so what's the work
you do you know I don't I think a lot of
people should build around their
interest in their hobbies businesses
because I think it's a more it's a I
think it's a better life to be happy and
make 200 thousand a year for fifty five
thousand or five thousand and be happy
then to make a million and be miserable
I really believe that it's not
sustainable unhappiness is not
sustainable but there's a lot of ways to
do it I'll give you an example if you
love football soccer football right okay
so that's your passion right now when
you think about a business when you go
back to the market do you build for
three three and a huge Instagram page do
you build a direct-to-consumer soccer
ball business do you buy the football
jerseys and resell them on Facebook
marketplace you see where I'm going so I
feel like there's a way to do both and
my opinion is if you love football then
you're gonna be willing to be up at 11
o'clock at night DMing and trying to
sell football jerseys whereas if you're
trying to do cryptocurrency because you
think there's money there you're not
interesting you're there for the money
it's gonna create some context of my
journey and just the opportunities for
so many of the people there's a there's
a huge mix of entrepreneurs employees
home takers so I'm gonna try to go wide
and then talk about the mindset and the
and the practicality around how you
create a level of happiness and
fulfillment through entrepreneurship in
a 20-19 environment
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
when I was a little kid in Edison New
Jersey when grandparents came over I
would go play with the grandparents a
lot a lot mainly was cuz I lost three of
my four grandparents as a kid and the
number one thing I learned in the first
20 years of my life spending more time
with old people than most kids is the
biggest thing I fear is regret regret is
scary resentment is very scary
the biggest reason I push kids to do
what they want versus what they parents
want is because I'd rather them in their
parents have five or six or seven years
of bad than 80 because it gets very ugly
when you're 60 and they're 80 and you
lived your life based on what they
wanted and now you resent them it gets
real ugly real fast
I would rather you have the pain for the
next five or six years of fighting and
then have one of two things happen which
I think both are amazing
number one you were right you were right
and you are an amazing fashion designer
not an engineer and you built a real
company and your parents are going to be
very very proud or you were wrong you
suck at fashion design nobody liked it
but at least for yourself you never have
to live the rest of your life asking
yourself what if you win both ways
you live in a culture I know I watch you
live in a culture with a lot of
expectations you live in a culture where
parents treat their kids as a property
that indicates who they are so does most
of the world
this is not a Southeast Asia thing this
is not a Indonesia thing this is a world
that parents are insecure to and they
like their kids closing their gap we
have to start talking about this let me
give a very big secret to all the kids
here who are living their lives for
their parents or based on their parents
judgment there's a very big secret that
parents never tell you that if you go
the other direction of where they want
you to go and you become really
successful they are really proud and
make pretend they never pushed you in
the other direction
don't let this energy go away one
[ __ ] life live it please live it go
work thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
and this is what happens when you
actually put out content from this place
in this place I think always the right
thing always
[Music]
really good energy was amazing super
young crowd at one point in a keynote
you see me asking how many people are
under 40
there was like eleven just spoke a lot
about mindset just trying to eliminate
excuses money and time does not excuse
anymore it's 2019 the internet lives
this is now mindset game people aren't
doing because of very silly mental
roadblocks I'm trying to eliminate those
roadblocks d-roc I'm trying to eliminate
that people should live by themselves I
mean not listening to other people's
opinion especially parents yes sometimes
it's very hot in Asia and do you have
any can you elaborate more on not
listening to your parents there yeah
it's not that I want to be disrespectful
to parents or things that nature it's
just an you know ultimately at the end
of the day one day you're gonna realize
your life is yours and there's a lot of
people important to you then surrounded
but ultimately it's yours
and I just think it's actually practical
to be selfish and on the offense in your
youth most people in their youth think
it's time to grow up but they're 18 22
25 29 years old and so I think the
social pressures normally from parents
or other friends starting to make money
or have success hurts people yet I think
that rushing into relationships jobs you
know is just not a smart strategy so I'm
talking about it and I'm hoping that
people are listening because I do think
that it's very hard to tune out your
parents I have empathy for that however
it doesn't make it wrong just because
it's hot you know to me to be very frank
the harder something is the more likely
it's fantastic so I I really meant what
I said on stage which I haven't
articulated that way often which is I'd
rather people struggle with their
parents in their 20s and 30s so that
they can have a great relationship with
them in their 40s 50s 60s 70s 80s and
90s versus always having a problem with
your parents and once you start living
your life based on what your parents
expectations are or anybody else's
you've begun the process of not being
that is just the truth who's happy doing
something that they don't want to be
doing nobody you may be content you may
deal with it but you're not happy I
think where parents make a huge mistake
is parents go attack you're gonna be
this you're gonna be a doctor you're
gonna be a lawyer instead of setting
back in the beginning and watching and
saying oh you should be a painter you
love to paint most parents attack my mom
and I'm like this in business too we're
like we're boxers who let the other it's
like good martial arts you let the other
person's force got it
so the way what she did was she she
fostered it by not forcing me to be
something I wasn't and giving me
opportunities to be who I was I'll give
you a good example
my mom would punish me when I got bad
grades she would punish me I would I
would get punished but if there was a
big baseball card show even if I was
punished she'd let me go no TV no
playing with friends but a big baseball
card show she'd let me go cause she knew
that's where I was building my future
[Music]
we go black huh yep yep so I went to
Jakarta for ten hours
and delivered this keynote was really
interesting de rock and I were just
talking I was did a couple interviews
which I'm sure created some good content
and one of the things that I observed
and indie-rock confirm which means it's
true is I've never stayed the course and
didn't be under to such a lively
audience there was so much energy so
much youthful energy here in Jakarta
that normally I would have gone super
cursed out super Chris Rock you know
Kevin Hart style and just made jokes and
but it was interesting I really stayed
the course on my message I hope you pick
up on that message in today's podcast
please enjoy
right now is the greatest most fruitful
most optimistic time in the history of
the world it is the date is black and
white health has never been better
medicine genocide war like the media
landscape and social media and
traditional media has been incredibly
effective in focusing on the negative
but the truth in the macro is go talk to
every grandparent of every millennial
and ask him if the world is better today
than it was when they were growing up
like there's a lot of good and so I
think couple things
is where I'm going with that I think a
lot a lot more people could be a lot
happier if they lived more humble if
they could just eliminate judgment of
other people I'm really passionate about
that I've been I've become outrageously
passionate about keeping up with the
Joneses as we call it in America like in
security
it kills you just you start doing things
that you can't afford your service
awesome yes so couple things it first
starts with the fact that you're putting
other people on a pedestal
you know it's very easy to get into a
sad place if you're surrounded by these
awesome people and you're just mediocre
I just don't believe that
I just don't think first of all I don't
think anybody is awesome or sucks from
this standpoint if somebody's good at
something
it also means they're not good at
something else and I think most people
dwell on what they're not good at and
they preys on what people are good at
and then reverse on themselves whereas
like I'm the reverse I think like I
think I'm great at certain things I
focus on that I'm aware that I suck at a
lot of things but I don't put other
people's strengths on a pedestal and and
most importantly I don't I hate that
people beat themselves up about their
shortcomings but then don't recognize it
in other people and give them a pass
because they're pretty or smart or funny
or have a lot of followers do you know
what I mean I think it's I think I
really believe the biggest driver that I
never had which is why it's so obvious
to me and why I talk about it a lot is
the judgment of other people of where
you should be at this point in your life
all these 57 year old parents that are
telling their 23 year old kids whether
they're a should be in life aren't where
they should be at 57 and so then they're
trying to make their kids there comes a
lot of times that comes from a good
place they don't want their kids to make
the same mistakes but but their kids are
living in a different world now this is
the part where probably d-roc ends with
a bunch of like footage of the airplane
like beautiful cloud landing you are
some little kid
and away we go
[Music]